[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public 90 minutes
de débats de reportage et d'analyse sur
Public Sénat la promesse et dans le
titre donner du sens à l'actualité vous
proposez des clés de compréhension des
crises que nous traversons et justement
notre débat actuel et consacré à
l'avenir de notre planète plus de 180
pays réunis à Montréal pour une copine
des Nations Unies consacrées à la
biodiversité un million d'espèces
menacées et donc un sommet pour sauver
la nature dont on va détailler les
enjeux dans une minute et puis dans
trois quarts d'heure on décolle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était le 16 novembre dernier la fusée
SLS prenait son envol de cap Carrera en
Floride pour placer la capsule Orion en
orbite autour de la Lune pourquoi
l'humanité repartait à la conquête de
notre satellite quels sont les enjeux
économiques et géopolitiques de l'espace
la France PESTEL encore dans cette
bataille ne ratez pas notre second débat
tout à l'heure mais d'abord donc la COP
15 c'est son nom présenté comme le
sommet de la dernière chance pour
préserver la biodiversité Jonathan du
priez
la tâche semble herculéenne en moins de
deux semaines la COP 15 sur la
biodiversité ambitionne d'aboutir à un
accord de la dernière chance pour sauver
les espèces et les milieux naturels
d'une destruction jugée irréversible on
est devant une crise de la biodiversité
c'est une crise qui est aussi réelle et
dangereuse que la crise crise climatique
c'est un enjeu majeur qui ne peut pas
être relégué au second plan parce qu'on
tous liés à la nature et le temps presse
un million d'espèces sont menacées
d'extinction et un tiers des terres
émergées de la planète sont gravement
dégradés dans le même temps la pollution
et le changement climatique ne cessent
d'aggraver la dégradation des océans à
la tribune le secrétaire général de
l'ONU a poussé ce cri d'alarme
les écosystèmes sont devenus les jouets
du profit avec notre appétit sans limite
pour une croissance économique
incontrôlée et inégale l'humanité est
devenue une arme d'extinction massive
nous traitons la nature comme des
toilettes et enfin de compte nous nous
suicidons par procuration
la COP 15 experts débouchés sur un
accord autour d'une vingtaine
d'objectifs comme la protection de 30%
des terres et des mers la restauration
des milieux naturels ou encore la
réduction de l'usage des pesticides mais
le consensus ne sera pas simple à
trouver
nous sommes déjà en retard au moins les
scientifiques nous disent qu'il n'est
pas encore trop tard mais que nous
allons vers un point de non-retours
alors si nous n'agissons pas maintenant
nous ne pourrons plus faire machine
arrière et la situation sera
irréversible mais la COP 15 pourrait
rencontrer plusieurs points de blocage
l'absence d'objectifs mesurable la mise
en place d'une compensation financière
des pays les plus riches pour la
biodiversité des pays en développement
ou encore l’épineuse question de la
biopyratrie dans les industries
cosmétiques et pharmaceutiques les
enjeux de cette conférence des Nations
Unies sur la biodiversité voilà le thème
de notre débat avec Claire Nouvion
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes fondatrice
de l'ONG Bloom pour la défense de
l'océan voici votre avant-dernière
publication la pêche industrielle à
l'assaut des airs marines dites protégée
j'accueille également Philippe grandcola
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi directeur
de recherche au CNRS directeur adjoint
scientifique de l'Institut écologie
environnement et entomologiste
spécialiste de l'évolution de la
biodiversité pierre Dubreuil bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi directeur
général de l'Office français de la
biodiversité qui a été créée en 2020 et
qui regroupe l'agence de la biodiversité
et l'Office national de la chasse et de
la faune sauvage Guillaume d'arrêt
éditeur et politique bonsoir Guillaume
et bienvenue à vous aussi comme de la
dernière chanson de la titré comme ça
mais en même temps claire nous vient on
a l'impression de répéter ça que ce soit
pour les coques climats pour les coques
biodiversité depuis des années et oui
qu'est-ce que je peux vous dire de plus
oui si on prenait si on était capable de
se projeter de prendre la mesure de
notre impact global avec nos toutes
petits cerveaux individuels dans cette
pièce en vérité on serait vraiment très
très déprimé et très inquiet et et j'ai
rencontré pas mal de gens récemment qui
me disaient je souffre déco anxiété et
ce terme qui est apparu c'est il est
réservé à ceux qui sont capables
justement cette projection parce que
notre trajectoire climatique on la
connaît bien maintenant elle est
épouvantable elle est elle est
catastrophique et on oublie tout le
temps que on est aussi en train de faire
disparaître les espèces sauvages mais de
façon très radicale les habitats les
animaux on les pollue on détruit on
fragmente les habitats et on va chasser
les espèces on les mange on les fait
disparaître on les fait brûler c'est
c'est une immense violence et on se dit
notre intelligence est quand même
capable de faire mieux que ça on est
capable d'envoyer les fusées sur la lune
entre les deux parce que c'est une des
critiques qui est faite au programme
spatiaux l'argent que ça coûte et ce
qu'on pourrait pas mettre cet argent
ailleurs
on est peut-être capable d'utiliser
notre intelligence pour faire mieux que
ce qu'on a fait c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui toute notre économie est
repose sur la destruction de
biodiversité il va falloir qu'elle passe
à la à la cohabitation harmonieuse donc
on va évidemment détailler tous ces
enjeux pendant 45 minutes Philippe bon
courage j'ai l'impression parfois que ça
que cet enjeu ce thème ce terme de
biodiversité il passe sous les radars
médiatiques mais peut-être aussi
politique on y viendra cette COP on
décide nous d'en parler j'ai quand même
le sentiment qu'elle est moins
médiatisée que la Coop sur le climat
c'est aussi votre avis peut-être
effectivement effectivement le mot
biodiversité est nouveau et il est des
années 80 il veut dire tout simplement
la diversité génétique entre les
individus les diversités qui résultent
de l'évolution entre les espèces et puis
la diversité entre les assemblages
d'espèces dans ce que l'on appelle des
écosystèmes des forêts des prairies des
savanes des océans avec des récifs
coralliens par exemple donc cette
diversité du vivant en fait elle met
l'accent sur les différences au lieu de
mettre l'accent uniquement sur les
points communs bien sûr tous les êtres
vivants descendent la même ancêtre avec
un support de l'hérédité une structure
cellulaire mais néanmoins ce qui nous
importe c'est qu'il y a des abeilles qui
pollinisent les fleurs ce qui nous
importe c'est qu'il y a des arbres qui
fertilisent les sols etc et c'est
différent c'est la biodiversité alors le
terme est nouveau néanmoins il y a
d'autres termes encore plus nouveau que
l'on s'empresse d'utiliser au quotidien
ou vous avez tous un smartphone n'est-ce
pas et ça ne vous choque pas d'utiliser
c'est ce terme est très étrangement le
terme biodiversité est encore objet
finalement de d'examen par la société
comme si on pouvait pas créer un terme
qui qui se remplace le terme un peu
confus un peu un peu
flou nature dans lequel on met un peu
tout et n'importe quoi voilà on retourne
à la nature parce qu'on n'y est pas on
est loin de la nature la biodiversité on
en est nous sommes une espèce de primate
qui a évoluée à partir d'un ancêtre
mammifère donc ce terme-là en fait est
toujours aujourd'hui est important de
l'utiliser d'autant plus qu'il a été
quelque part sacralisée par la
Convention sur la diversité biologique
le Sommet de la Terre à Rio en 92 et
maintenant c'est un terme qui a une
valeur juridique effectivement
contraignante pour les presque 200 pays
qui ont signé cette convention et avec
ces on va donner quelques chiffres
évidemment pendant ce débat c'est c'est
ces informations qui viennent de la
plateforme intergouvernementale sur la
biodiversité et les services
écosystémiques c'est un peu le GIEC de
la biodiversité pour pour simplifier 75%
de l'environnement terrestre 66 du
milieu marin ont été significativement
modifiée par l'action humaine pierre
Dubreuil mettre la biodiversité et je
parlais de de radar ou d'agenda
politique aux médiatique c'est un peu
votre votre mission oui c'est la mission
de l'Office français de la biodiversité
qui comme vous l'avez dit est un
établissement nouveau une fusion mais
comme la défi brancola il y a un
paradoxe de la biodiversité c'est que
huit Français sur 10 considèrent que
c'est un mot qui fait peur enfin c'est
des études d'opinion qui dit ça et en
même temps disent que c'est important
donc on a un vrai problème pour faire
comprendre ce qu'il y a derrière ce
mobiliversité ce que Philippe disait le
vivant et le rôle de l'ofb qui a
beaucoup de missions c'est notamment de
mobiliser toute la société tous les
acteurs les pêcheurs les agriculteurs
les chasseurs les entreprises pour
préserver cette biodiversité qui est
finalement le vivant commun c'est la
nature avec l'homme c'est pas l'homme
contre la nature les mots du Secrétaire
général des Nations Unies sont très
forts une arme l'homme est devenu une
arme de destruction massive et bien
l'homme et la cause mais l'homme doit
être la solution et l'homme peut être la
solution et notre rôle c'est de
mobiliser toute la société de faire en
sorte que chacun s'approprie cet enjeu
commun parce que c'est finalement la
biodiversité vous savez c'est ce que
vous mangez c'est ce que vous buvez
c'est ce que vous respirez c'est ce que
vous portez c'est ce qu'on porte donc
faire comprendre ça à tous les citoyens
c'est pas facile mais c'est l'enjeu mais
mais quand vous vous rappelez les propos
de du Secrétaire général des Nations
unies dans le livre de de Yuval noir
harissa piens il rappelle que au début
de l'humanité ça bien c'est le pire
sérieux qui leur de l'histoire c'est à
dire qu'il y a toutes les grosses
espèces qui existaient sur tous les
continents des espèces géantes à chaque
fois que ça piace mais le pied sur un
nouveau continent ces espèces
disparaissent alors c'est c'est
finalement enfin c'est je vais essayer
de pas être trop pessimiste pendant ce
débat mais on se dit que c'est ce n'est
que la continuité parce qu'on est en
train de vivre alors c'est peut-être une
un résumé un peu un peu
voilà de l'évolution humaine et puis et
puis des premières sociétés qui étaient
comme on dit chasseuse cueilleuse bon
cela dit malgré tous aujourd'hui il y a
des sociétés qui ont encore un mode de
vie qui se rapproche de ces sociétés
humaines et notamment certains peuples
autochtones l'IPE justement la rappeler
à bonne cet été en 2022 c'est quoi alors
l'IPBES se libère la plateforme
intergouvernementale sur la biodiversité
j'avais pas le la chronique en tête
c'est pour ça d'accord
un milliard et demi de personnes qui
vivent directement de l'utilisation des
espèces sauvages donc notre monde n'est
pas entièrement limité
aux grandes villes et aux pays
industrialisés et cet utilisation est
absolument indispensable comme l'a dit
Pierre Dubreuil on porte des vêtements
en coton ou en laine on vit on mange de
la biodiversité donc finalement on est
passé d'un certain mode d'exploitation
directe à des modes d'agriculture et
d'élevage qui ont aussi leurs
problématiques évidemment claire nous
vient on oublie pas que la terre c'est
la planète bleue et que donc la
biodiversité elle est aussi ou d'abord
d'ailleurs je ne sais pas océanique ah
bah oui la vie est apparu dans l'eau ça
je pense que personne ne peut contredire
ça et elle est en train de disparaître
dans l'eau d'ailleurs aussi puisque vous
disiez en effet que partout où l'humain
est présent il y a eu des phénomènes
d'extinction ou des phénomènes de
modification de l'environnement en
revanche l'accélération qui est due aux
technologies qui sont qui sont apparus
avec
la révolution industrielle sont vraiment
des changements qui sont majeurs et on
le voit d'ailleurs dans l'eau vous avez
vu les chiffres qui viennent d'être
évalués l'un sur les le nombre de
baleines qu'on avait tués en fait on est
plutôt à 3 millions de baleines dans
l'histoire de l'humain 3 millions de
baleines qu'on aurait fait disparaître
avec de la chasse industrielle ça veut
dire qu'en biomasse c'est la plus grande
tuerie de l'histoire de l'humanité c'est
que même les bisons même les extinctions
de mammifères etc ne correspondent pas à
cette immense saccage des baleines alors
que ça fait le lien avec le climat parce
que d'une baleine
une baleine une grande baleine va
capturer dans sa vie autant si ce n'est
plus que 1500 arbres donc quand on a
même pas une passion pour les animaux ou
la nature bien que il soit prouvé je
pense maintenant que chacun respire
mieux quand on a la campagne qu'on est
entouré de bruit d'animaux et de la
beauté des animaux mais même par intérêt
un pur calcul égocentrique sur
nous-mêmes on a intérêt à avoir des
animaux dans l'eau et y compris des
grands poissons parce qu'on a fait
disparaître 90% des prédateurs depuis
1950 seulement les grands prédateurs
c'est les tons c'est les mérous c'est
les requins etc donc on a on est en
train de faire disparaître le vivant
autour de nous on est un c'est vraiment
c'est pour ça que ce sommet en fait
traite d'enjeux qui sont existentiels et
que il faut vraiment que ça remonte en
visibilité merci d'ailleurs de faire une
émission sur le sujet parce que comme
vous dites tout le monde conn logique
personne connaît l'IPBES effectivement
ce qui est quand même le pendant du GIEC
pour la biodiversité ce qui est fou et
alors la COP 15 pardon mais franchement
c'est mal choisi parce qu'il y a une COP
21 à côté une COP15 de l'autre on s'y
perd on sait plus enfin on pourrait
réunir les deux mais ça on y viendra
peut-être je voudrais vraiment qu'on se
concentre sur les les enjeux de cette
conférence des Nations Unies sur la
biodiversité avec matthiasarès qui doit
être juste derrière le rideau bonsoir
Mathias bonsoir bien bienvenue à vous
alors il y a 196 pays je crois quel
accord peut-on espérer à quel type
d'accord tente-t-il d'aboutir bah
écoutez l'objectif est clair et visiter
une sixième extinction de masse en
mettant un terme à la perte de nature
d'ici 2030 rien que ça alors ça passe
par arrêter d'artificialiser les sols
par exemple purifier l'eau beaucoup
d'options sont mises sur la table avec
une mesure phare qui est déjà attendu
instaurer la protection d'au moins 30%
des zones terrestres et maritimes contre
17 et 8% aujourd'hui bref un accord qui
ne devra pas être petit bras et dans
lequel chacun devra mettre du sien comme
la souligner la directrice générale du
Programme des Nations Unies Inger
Anderson
nous n'avons que quelques jours pour
agir de manière décisive et avec des
principes l'action doit être audacieuse
et non mise entre parenthèses afin que
nous puissions conclure cet accord
quelles sont les chances d'y arriver
pour arriver à un accord les acteurs
sont plutôt optimistes cette COP15 était
très attendue elle a été tout de même
reportée deux fois à cause du covid et
il faut dire que les arguments donnés
cette année ils pèsent dans la balance
vous le savez Thomas rien de tel que de
frapper aux porte-monnaies c'est bien de
ça dont il est question cette année
notamment selon un rapport rendu par
l'ONG WWF ne rien faire pour stopper la
disparition de la biodiversité serait
estimée à tenez-vous bien 479 milliards
de dollars par an soit quasiment le PIB
de la Thaïlande un raisonnement qui
devrait notamment parler aux
multinationales seulement voilà Thomas
j'ai voulu mesurer la différence entre
la parole et les actes je me suis donc
replongé dans les mesures prises lors de
la COP 14 c'était en 2018 à
sharm-el-sheik on y retrouvait parmi les
quatre engagements notamment les étapes
parties se sont engagés à accélérer
leurs efforts pour atteindre en 2020 les
objectifs d'eishi pour la biodiversité
les États se sont engagés à des
contributions volontaires en faveur de
la biodiversité dans la déclaration de
charme melcheck les objectifs des
objectifs floues et peu chiffrés qui
laissent espérer une autre issue cette
année et la question c'est est-ce que
cet accord sera ou non contraignant et
bien c'est difficile à dire mais on ne
semble pas en prendre le chemin
malheureusement comme dans toutes les
grandes messes internationales on pense
à l'accord de Paris de la COP 21 au
protocole de Kyoto la variable
contrainte elle fait peur aux États et
aux multinationales qui sont partis
prenantes l'un des meilleurs exemples de
cette lutte contre l'interdiction ou
même la limitation et l'une des mesures
portées par la coalition business for
nature qui tend vers une autorégulation
des entreprises on parlerait là d'une
obligation d'évaluer et communiquer son
impact et le degré de dépendance
vis-à-vis de la nature merci Mathias
pierre Dubreuil cette SAU de la
biodiversité si on essaye d'être concret
ça doit quoi ça doit être posé par
exemple par un décideur qui soit
politique ou économique avant chaque
nouveau projet ça l'a pas forcément été
est-ce que ça commence à l'être qu'elle
va être l'impact de mon projet quel
impact sur la biodiversité c'est-à-dire
que c'est une révolution conceptuelle
c'est-à-dire que il faut considérer que
dans chaque activité humaine on se pose
la question de l'impact que ça aura sur
la nature activité industrielle activité
quand on construit par exemple activités
alors le pêche puisqu'on parle de
l'océan activité économique quelle
qu'elle soit une entreprise aujourd'hui
alors c'est le rôle de l'OSB
d'accompagner ces acteurs notamment ces
entreprises à intégrer la biodiversité
dans leur stratégie elles le font pour
le climat il y a des stratégies RSE pour
stratégie bas carbone bon et ben pour
les pour les biodiversité c'est la même
chose donc l'objectif c'est
d'accompagner les entreprises des
acteurs économiques et tous les acteurs
sociaux et le citoyens vous moi pour
qu'à chaque décision que nous prenons on
se pose la question est-ce que
quel impact savoir sur la nature c'est
pas évident à calculer c'est pas évident
à mesurer il y a une question aussi de
mesure c'est plus facile de calculer le
degré de température ou la tonne carbone
pour la biodiversité et là je me tourne
vers les scientifique il savent bien la
mesure est plus complexe parce que c'est
une question n'interdépendance de
dynamique d'interaction entre espèces
milieu écosystème mais il nous faut nous
travailler c'est ce qu'on fait aussi à
l'ofb sur des indicateurs relativement
simple qui permettent de mesurer
l'impact de l'homme sur la biodiversité
et l'évolution de cet impact alors on va
prendre un exemple qui est très concret
et que vous portez clair nuance et celui
des des aires protégés puisque c'est
l'un des enjeux de cette conférence des
Nations Unies sur la sur la biodiversité
déjà alors vous allez nous le dire pour
l'océan même si ça vaut aussi pour le
évidemment les les zones terrestres mais
c'est quoi une aire protégée alors une
hyper protégée il y a une définition une
aire marine protégée définition très
claire de l'UICN c'est à dire l'Union
internationale pour la conservation de
la nature
nous explique une aire marine protégée
pour qu'elle puisse s'appeler comme ça
c'est à dire protéger ça veut dire qu'il
n'y a pas d'activité industrielle ça
veut dire qu'il n'y a pas d'activité
extractive que ce soit d'extraction de
sable de minerais ou de la pêche qui a
un impact sur le fond donc pour préciser
encore l'Union internationale pour la
conservation de la nature même défini ce
qu'on appelait la pêche industrielle et
la pêche industrielle c'est la pêche qui
fait plus de 12 mètres ou alors toute
pêche peu importe la taille qui rate le
fond donc on a une définition très
claire une aire moyenne protégée au
globale une arme à une protégée on
interdit des activités industrielles
mais on autorise en fait les activités
artisanales c'est-à-dire des pêches
sélectives qui n'ont pas d'impact sur le
fond des bateaux qui font moins de 12
mètres voilà une heure marine protégée
et ensuite à l'intérieur des aires
marines protégées il faut des airs de
protection strictes c'est de la
protection intégrale en anglais ça
s'appelle No take je crois que c'est à
peu près tout le monde à peu près le
niveau pour comprendre ne prend rien on
met la nature sous cloche et l'objectif
c'est d'avoir 30% d'air marine protégée
dans le monde
et 10% à l'intérieur de cette 30% donc
en fait il faudrait 20% d'air moyenne
protégées et 10% de protection strictes
où on met la nature sous cloche et c'est
là évidemment que la nature se restaure
de façon spectaculaire et j'insiste
parce que parce que le temps on a le
temps pour une fois merci de bien
distinguer la biodiversité c'est-à-dire
les espèces la richesse biologique des
espèces et les habitats et les habitats
marins il faut se représenter que sous
l'eau il y a des forêts sauf que ce ne
sont pas des forêts qui sont faites par
des plantes sont des forêts qui sont
conçues par des animaux des Gorgones qui
fabriquent des coraux etc qui fabriquent
des alors c'est des forêts plus petites
mais ce sont quand même des forêts
animales et bien dans une aire
totalement protégée de protection
stricte alors on arrête de faire passer
ces engins qui détruisent aussi les
habitats donc les animaux se portent
mieux on a jusqu'à 670% de biomasse en
plus
et les habitats se reconstruisent et
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on a on a des
chalutiers de fond c'est à dire des
engins qui sont tractés qui transforment
en permanence ces forêts animales en
désert on va évidemment prendre le temps
vous allez le titre de ce fascicule de
ce c'est les airs marines dites
protégées donc on a bien compris je vais
pas du tout je vais vous laisser
expliquer tout à l'heure mais je
voudrais que vous lui expliquiez alors
peut-être là pour le coup sur terre
effectivement là si on fait bien le
travail dans une dans une aire protégée
la biodiversité parce qu'on va essayer
d'être aussi un peu positif de temps en
temps ça ça renait ça revient la nature
reprend ses droits c'est le cliché mais
assez vite oui tout à fait effectivement
il y a une dynamique naturelle qui on le
sait tous est basé sur tout simplement
la reproduction à partir du moment où il
y a des organismes qui ont des
descendants autant de descendance
multiplient et puis on a une sorte de
croissance exponentielle alors bien sûr
il y a des prédateurs ou des
antagonistes qui peuvent limiter un peu
cette croissance mais d'une manière
générale effectivement le vivant reprend
ses droits d'autant plus que dans un une
simple forêt par exemple en France
métropolitaine on a non seulement
quelques des dizaines d'espèces de
plantes mais on a aussi quelques
milliers d'espèces d'insectes et puis
quelques millions d'espèces de bactéries
quelques milliers d'espèces de
champignons microscopiques donc on a
vraiment une dynamique qui peut
s'installer relativement rapidement et
c'est pour ça qu'il y a ce concept d'air
protégé parce qu'à l'intérieur de cette
aire on va avoir une trajectoire un
petit peu plus spontanée et quelque part
c'est ce que l'on appelle aujourd'hui
une solution fournie sur la nature c'est
une solution pour l'humanité parce que
ça veut dire qu'on n'est pas obligé
d'intervenir en permanence dans une
culture ou dans un système hydroponique
pour pour que cet écosystème finalement
se perpétue donc on en tire un bénéfice
immédiat à condition d'avoir un certain
respect des processus ce qui implique
effectivement selon les statuts très peu
de prise un petit peu de prise mais pas
violent de manière que le système puisse
se perpétuer naturellement mais alors je
vais dire un gros mot ça coûte cher
c'est à dire que là si on se si on se
projette dans les enjeux de cette comme
biodiversité à Montréal et qu'on veut
effectivement augmenter la superficie la
surface des aires protégées ça coûte
cher ça coûte infiniment moins cher que
le fait de réparer dégâts que l'on
commet quand on perturbe les écosystèmes
alors le problème c'est à quel budget
ces sommes sont-elles imputées si les
bénéfices que l'on en tire sont imputés
effectivement à la fois aux utilisateurs
des pêcheurs dans des écosystèmes qui
sont surpêchés ne disposeront plus de
stocks et devront cesser leur activité à
terme par contre effectivement si les
bénéfices sont si les déficits sont
imputés quelque part à la société que
les bénéfices parviennent uniquement les
bénéfices d'une destruction parvienne
uniquement par exemple à certains
groupes commerciaux de pêche
industrielle ou d'exploitation sylvicole
et là effectivement il y a un problème
d'imputation des budgets et les étapes
peuvent être tentés quelque part de
laisser faire certaines activités
industrielles pour cette raison alors
très vite mais dans l'océan c'est très
simple quand on protège ça coûte rien
c'est gratuit on protège et ça rapporte
en fait c'est prouvé puisqu'en fait
aujourd'hui on est quand même dans un
état de surpêche et donc de destruction
de la pêche artisanale on a laissé
tomber nos pêcheurs c'est vraiment une
hémorragie dans l'emploi c'est un
secteur qui se porte mal alors que si on
permet la reconstitution des stocks
c'est quand même la seule grande
activité de cueillette à l'échelle
industrielle au niveau planétaire les
pêcheurs artisanaux ils peuvent pas
travailler on appelle ça du speed over
c'est à dire que ça fait les poissons
les poissons se reproduisent seulement
qui finissent par déborder et vous savez
les premiers défenseurs des airmines
protégés vraiment protégés ce sont les
pêcheurs ils finissent par dire mais ne
nous enlevez pas notre grenier à poisson
en fait pierre du bruit ça fait partie
de votre mission quand Emmanuel Macron
vous nomme à la tête de de cette office
français de la biodiversité de faire
grandir les les aires protégés ça fait
partie vous savez nous gérons nous des
aires protégés desert terrestres et des
arts marines des parcs naturels marins
c'est nous qui les girons à l'ofb alors
moi je suis d'accord avec le dernier mot
qui vient de directeur il faut pas
opposer les pêcheurs et la protection
c'est à dire que nous on est là pour
faire comprendre que une aire protégée
c'est l'homme avec la biodiversité
évidemment il y a une notion de
protection forte mais si on veut arriver
à 30 %, il faut concilier les activités
humaines avec la protection je vous
donne un exemple quand il y avait plus
de ton rouge en Méditerranée les
premières victimes c'était les pêcheurs
ce qui pouvait plus vendre le thon rouge
il pourrait il pourrait plus en vivre
ils ont arrêté de pêcher le thon rouge
le thon rouge est revenu aujourd'hui
l'espèce se porte mieux c'était il y a
10 ou 15 ans et bien il faut raisonner
comme ça de manière intelligente et
adaptative pour tout parfois il y a des
milieux qui se portent tellement mal
qu'il faut totalement arrêter et et il y
a des zones de protection intégrales et
puis il y a des milieux dans lesquels on
peut concilier les activités humaines de
pêche artisanales et nous on anime ça en
fait avec une gouvernance locale avec
des pêcheurs avec des scientifiques avec
des citoyens et ça fonctionne mais alors
avec quelle exhi
dites-nous pourquoi vous pourquoi vous
dites protégé ça fonctionne super bien
l'étude que je vous ai offertes on a
quantifié la présence des pêcheurs
industriels à l'intérieur des aires
marines protégées il pêche autant à
l'intérieur d'une aire marine dites
protégé qu'à l'extérieur ça vous savez
global fishing watch maintenant les
données sont publiques et on peut
utiliser tous autant qu'on est chez un
organisme c'est en fait les données
satellites des bateaux sont maintenant
disponibles donc nous ça permet à nos
data c'est indice à nos chercheurs
d'utiliser la donnée satellite pour en
effet quand vous dites que vous avez des
preuves que de la pêche intensive et
pratiquée dans les airs dites protégées
d'ailleurs par un chercheur du CNRS qui
me claudait auquel je pense qu'on peut
un petit peu faire hommage parce qu'il
c'est le premier qui a vraiment
quantifié les zones qui sont vraiment
protégées en France parce que notre
président de la République se targue
d'avoir protégé plus de 30% des heures
des eaux françaises donc bravo cocorico
etc et Joachim Claudet a montré qu'en
fait la vraie protection et les homos
métropolitaines serait façade manche et
Atlantique c'est
0,005% de protection et dans la façade
sur la façade méditérienne c'est
0,094% et donc toute notre protection
qu'on dit forte parce que en France on a
réinventé le vocabulaire et on a on a
changé mais ça je veux bien qu'on y
revienne 2 minutes on a changé les
catégories au lieu de prendre les
catégories européennes de protection
strictes en France on a inventé la
protection forte et on a redéfini le
protection forte et dans la protection
forte à la française et bien on interdit
rien c'est quand même merveilleux alors
votre réponse on va faire le bilan des
Macron dans un instant pardon de vous
interrompre j'essaye de de distribuer la
parole à peu près équitablement
protégées il y a un petit souci elles
sont déjà écoutez moi je peux vous dire
je fais de la coopération internationale
notamment avec l'Afrique du Sud qui nous
demande des conseils sur la manière dont
on gère je dis pas que c'est parfait et
il faut sans doute aller plus loin mais
en France on dispose de parc naturel
marins qui manque encore peut-être de
moyens qui m'ont posé d'ambition mais
qui existe où on a une gouvernance pour
protéger ces espèces et ces milieux et
après la question des zones de
protection forte le président de la
République à Marseille congrès modèle
nature dit on va multiplier par 25 alors
c'est 0,2 en Méditerranée et 25 x 0,2 ça
fait 0 ça fait que 5 % mais c'est quand
même c'est comme un progrès alors après
il y a la définition de ces zones de
protection forte et on doit quand même
discuter avec c'est la philosophie
d'établissement que je dirige avec les
acteurs économiques et notamment avec
les pêcheurs pour savoir aussi comment à
quel endroit on peut pas je pense
décréter comme ça d'arrêter toute
activité humaine il faut le faire sur la
base de constat scientifique il faut le
faire aussi dans le dialogue avec des
parties prenantes moi c'est ma
conviction maintenant je reconnais de
toute façon il faut aller plus loin bien
sûr il faut aller plus loin et quand le
président de la République dit objectif
30-30 enfin c'est un objectif qui est
porté à la COP15 il le porte de même que
ça veut dire que ce soit
océan ou terrestre à l'horizon 2030
il a également enfin c'est quelque chose
transporte aussi l'interdiction
d'exploitation des fonds marins quelque
chose que la France peut alors vous
savez quoi merci de citer ça parce que
c'est exactement ce qu'il nous faut pour
les aires marines protégées en fait
entretenu responsable pour 15 ans de non
protection de la France en revanche si
vous pouviez dire puisque vous avez
l'oreille du président lui dire mais
vous savez quoi faites comme ce que vous
avez fait pour le l'extraction des
minerais en profondeur faites pareil
annoncez que la France protège vraiment
ses aires protégées et qu'on va se
mettre au niveau des finitions
internationales de l'UICN que une herma
est protégée interdit les activités
industrielles si vous êtes d'accord avec
ça vous allez porter ce message là
le président de la République va porter
le discours
il l'a porté et d'ailleurs le
gouvernement dans la délégation
française dans laquelle je serai
modestement avec les ministres nous
portons ça
ça a disparu du mandat du conseil de
l'UEFA
et vous aurez de nouveau la parole parce
que puisqu'on est sur la question du
bilan en quelque sorte écologique ou
environnementale d'Emmanuel Macron
Guillaume d'arrêt justement alors vous
employez l'expression que moi j'emploie
pour pour les cabinets de conseils et le
dossier mais ça peut valoir aussi vous
dire que c'est le le sparada du
président alors on parlait du bilan il y
a aussi le projet pour ce second mandat
parce que rappelez-vous Emmanuel Macron
c'était à Marseille justement durant la
campagne d'entre deux tours il avait
affiché son ambition il avait expliqué
que son second quinquennat je cite
serait écologique ou ne serait pas et
façon de montrer que pour lui c'était
quelque chose d'important il avait même
dit que c'était le premier ministre en
l'occurrence la première ministre
elle-même qui serait directement en
charge de ces questions avec deux
ministres effectivement à la transition
énergétique un autre à la transition
écologique sur ce point là on peut pas
dire que c'est franchement réussi pour
l'instant parce que je pense que
Elisabeth borne elle est pas franchement
identifié pour l'instant en tant que
première ministre à l'écologie mais bien
davantage par exemple on le voit en ce
moment
à la question de la réforme des
retraites Emmanuel Macron lui-même sur
le plan médiatique effectivement on le
voit constamment essayer de défendre son
bilan sur cette question de l'écologie
et on l'a vu d'ailleurs très récemment
essayer de cibler plus directement les
jeunes en faisant des questions réponses
directement sur les réseaux sociaux sur
Internet en répondant aux questions que
les Français pouvaient lui poser mais on
voit qu'effectivement pour l'instant ça
n'imprime pas pourquoi ça n'imprime pas
alors ça imprime pas parce que c'est
proche le conseil c'est un converti sur
cette question ça faisait pas partie de
son logiciel au départ Emmanuel Macron
on voit qu'effectivement c'était pas
central non plus dans son projet de la
première candidature en 2017 et donc
faut le reconnaître aussi il fait un peu
l'objet d'un procès d'attention en
permanence d'une partie des écologistes
qui le juge en permanence un sincère sur
cette question ça n'imprime pas aussi
parce que là c'est de sa faute il y a
aussi un problème de lisibilité comme
sur d'autres sujets on a du mal à voir
quel est le projet qu'est-ce qui veut
porter et ça a été renforcé notamment
parce qu'elle était considéré comme un
aller-retour notamment sur la question
nucléaire on a eu un président qui a dit
qu'il allait fermer 14 réacteurs en 2018
qui a annoncé que là on allait en
rouvrir d'autres et donc ça pas arranger
la lisibilité de la de la dimension
écologique de son de son projet et puis
ça imprime pas aussi parce qu'on peut
voir depuis le départ du trait
médiatique Nicolas Hulot j'ai regardé il
y a 5 ministres qui se sont succédés
François de Rugy Élisabeth borne Barbara
pompieri Méline manchalin de façon très
très brève puis Christophe déchu et faut
le reconnaître il y en a aucun d'entre
eux qui a réussi à incarner ce combat et
dans le même temps on a réussi ce qui
était pas le cas des des monnaures
précédentes à avoir un ministre de
l'économie à Bercy qui reste lui-même
donc comme quoi c'est possible sur
certaines thématiques comment les les
Français jugent le gouvernement le
président de la République sur ce thème
de l'équipe d'énergie pas si mal que ça
il faut pas qu'ils décourage si j'ose
dire si il nous entend le chef de l'État
sur cette question parce que quand on
regarde les différentes études d'opinion
qui ont été fait très récemment on peut
prendre par exemple cette qualité faite
par l'Institut hilab en novembre dernier
justement au moment de la Coop
directement sur la question du
dérèglement climatique alors certes il y
a encore 53% des Français d'après cette
étude qui estiment que le gouvernement
n'en fait pas assez contre que le
dérèglement climatique mais ce qui est
intéressant de voir c'est l'évolution et
l'évolution c'est finalement se
mécontentement il est 16 points moins
important que trois ans avant donc c'est
à dire qu'il conserve pour l'instant un
certain crédit sur cette question et
quand on se plonge dans le baromètre
vous savez de l'Ifop qui a publié dans
le JDD qui est l'historique des
présidents qui est publié tous les mois
on voit que par exemple quand on regarde
plus précisément les Français qui se
disent proches d'Europe Écologie Les
Verts et bien il y en a 36% d'entre eux
qui sont satisfaits du bilan d'Emmanuel
Macron alors c'est le bilan dans
l'ensemble mais qui sont satisfaits de
l'action du chef de l'État et ça c'est
en progression de 10 points par rapport
au dernier mois ça veut dire
qu'effectivement Emmanuel Macron malgré
les critiques conservent une forme de
crédit sur cette question de l'écologie
à lui de le conserver ce crédit de le
faire fructifier
un converti parfois les convertis sont
les plus assidus dans les lieux de culte
il faut pas l'oublier Philippe roccola
qu'est-ce que vous attendez vous alors
d'Emmanuel Macron est peut-être plus
généralement des des politiques puisque
là on est sur une coop avec 196 pays
représentés on parle d'extinction des
espèces ça veut dire qu'il y a des sur
lesquels on peut concrètement agir pour
freiner cette extinction
analogue du siècle sur le biodiversité
la catégorisé les leviers en 5 grands
groupes en fait tout simplement il
s'agit de changer les systèmes de
manière plus exercée les pressions comme
la disparition des habitats des
forestations etc les pollutions les
prélèvements excessifs la surpêche par
exemple les espèces exotiques
envahissantes ou également le changement
climatique avec des interactions dans
les deux sens avec la biodiversité donc
si on lève ces pressions effectivement
on laisse la biodiversité reprendre ses
aises et on bénéficie des services qu'on
considère d'ordinaire comme immanent le
fait d'avoir une eau de boissons une eau
pure le fait d'avoir une alimentation de
produire une alimentation sans
plafonnement le fait de ne pas être
affecté par des maladies émergentes il
faut rappeler depuis 1950 on a 300 pics
épidémiques ou d'apparition de Mali
émergentes qui sont liées également à la
fragmentation du milieu naturel tout
simplement la mise en contact des
humains avec des réservoirs animaux qui
sont dans des milieux de qui était
beaucoup plus intègre donc l'ensemble de
ces problèmes on peut les lever on peut
les faire diminuer en laissant
effectivement non seulement des airs
sous protection mais également ne
traitant pas n'importe comment les
espaces qui sont en dehors des
protections et là c'est aussi l'objet
des négociations dans la coque on parle
de restauration c'est à dire des
écosystèmes qui sont actuellement dans
un très mauvais état par exemple des
systèmes agro-industriels avec des
champs à perte de vue sans haie avec des
intrants en quantité considérable ces
écosystèmes-là on peut les restaurer
dans une certaine mesure les rayons
sauvagés si l'on peut dire pour une
partie de leur surface et puis il y a
également d'autres actions envisager
simplement à opérer une transition
agricole limiter l'élevage industriel on
sait qu'aujourd'hui on produit de
manière extraordinaire de quoi nourrir
bien plus que le monde simplement cette
production agricole et d'élevage elle
est pas distribuée correctement elle est
liée aussi une quantité de viande
consommée par les gens majoritairement
pauvres et à faible niveau d'éducation
qui mine présenter donc on est vraiment
dans un système qu'il faut arriver à
transformer petit à petit et là
évidemment on s'oppose à un certain
nombre de personnes dont les activités
économiques sont particulièrement
importantes en termes de pesticides en
termes de fabrication d'un tronc et en
terme de production industrielle de
nourriture est-ce qu'il faut du courage
politique pour s'attaquer au lobby de la
pêche je fais le lien et ça rejoint ce
que vous ce que les critiques finalement
exprimées par Claire noubian
il faut évidemment du courage politique
pour comme le dit vient de le dire
Philippe grand Cola changer de modèle et
faire évolu le modèle bien sûr mais le
courage politique doit s'accompagner du
dialogue encore une fois avec les
parties prenantes je le répète il suffit
pas de décréter le changement il faut le
faire vivre ce changement et
bien sûr avec les pêcheurs comme avec
les agriculteurs vous ne ferez pas la
transition contre bien sûr vous ferez la
transition avec passant mais avec 100%
d'accord avec vous sauf que dans
l'équation il y a quelque chose de
compliqué qui est ça prend le changement
de modèle économique prend du temps il y
a beaucoup de grandes entreprises qui
sont en train de faire basculer leur
modèle économique c'est vrai mais sauf
qu'on a face à une urgence climatique et
en matière de biodiversité bien sûr mais
on doit c'est là que les scientifiques
sont très importants et Philippe grand
cola et membres du conseil scientifique
de l'ofb on doit éclairer la société et
les acteurs les pêcheurs les
agriculteurs les entreprises à l'aune du
constat scientifique bien sûr qu'il y a
urgence à agir mais il faut que chacun
comprenne qu'on quand je disais tout à
l'heure que on en mange on en boit on
porte à biodiversité c'est les citoyens
qui vont permettre de faire évoluer le
modèle et qui aussi en consommant au
consommant pas vont faire évoluer les
pratiques donc par exemple la
déforestation à portée pardon de le dire
mais là encore c'est une initiative
européenne et qui a été portée par le
Président de la République on interdit
la déforestation importée c'est une
pratique commerciale qui va qui doit
changer les choses et qui va sans doute
avoir un impact réel sur la biodiversité
la résilience des forêts et sur la santé
alors effectivement c'est un accord qui
vient d'être signé au niveau européen je
vais détailler un peu les l'importation
de produits issus de la déforestation
cacao café soja huile de palme il y a le
bois il y a la viande bovine le
caoutchouc qui sont concernés il y a des
produits des matières associés c'est le
terme employé cuir ameublement papier
imprimé charbon de bois donc c'est
effectivement un accord assez vaste je
vous propose d'entendre pardon je vous
redonne la parole après sur ce thème le
porte-parole de la Commission européenne
les nouvelles règles créeront un devoir
de vigilance donc du de Legends pour les
entreprises qui souhaitent placer sur le
marché européen cette bien ou leurs
produits dérivés il s'agit de l'huile de
palme du bétail du soja du cacao du bois
et du caoutchouc l'accord fera partie de
la contribution européenne à la
Conférence mondiale sur la biodiversité
la COP 15 qui est en train de démarrer à
Montréal pierre Duboy c'est alors là on
parlait d'accord contraignant ou pas là
on est dans un accord contraignant
pose un acte je crois que c'est 16% de
la déforestation importée dont l'y Open
est responsable en fait finalement donc
c'est pas négligeable et bien sûr
derrière ça va s'appliquer j'espère dans
les accords commerciaux et dans le
désimportations de produits qu'on n'aura
plus là vous avez vraiment le lien avec
le avec le courage et la décision
politique qui doit avoir un impact sur
la biodiversité ensuite et sur le
maintien d'espèces du milieu
d'écosystèmes c'est très concret alors
évidemment l'Europe c'est pas grand
chose à l'échelle du monde ça n'est que
16% mais c'est un aiguillon qui j'espère
permettra à la COP15 d'être ambitieux je
peux rien dire sur quelque chose parce
que je j'ai quand même deux trois je
voudrais juste revenir avec un petit un
petit traité de terrain la semaine
prochaine c'est dimanche s'ouvre la
négociation des ministres de la pêche
vous savez sur le la foire d'emploi
annuelle sur les quotas de pêche et au
niveau européen au niveau européen
d'accord ça fait 20 ans que les
scientifiques alertent sur l'état de
dégradation proche de l'extinction de
l'anguille et la Commission a proposé
déjà une fermeture en 2017 combattue par
la France là elle a proposé un plan
d'action vraiment urgent en disant
urgence menace d'extinction de l'espèce
qui mène la fronde pour que surtout on
n'écoute pas les avis scientifiques la
France aujourd'hui même pendant que je
vous parle sur les côtes de la Manche en
face de Dunkerque de Calais face à nos
pécheurs artisans abandonné déjà par la
France au moment du débat sur la scène
des mersals je sais pas si vous avez
suivi un peu ce débat d'une méthode de
pêche qui détruit les fonds inventés par
les Néerlandais des énormes bateaux
industriels qui qui vraiment une méthode
de pêche qui détruit l'océan les animaux
marins le climat et les pêcheurs
artisans français
98% des pêcheurs artisans français
demandaient l'interdiction de la scène
des mersal la France n'a pas obtempéré
et a abandonner ses pêcheurs et à par
contre soutenu les lobbies industriels
des bateaux des grands bateaux
industriels néerlandais aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui pendant qu'on se parle il y
a trois bateaux qui font plus de 100
mètres 88 mètres 126 mètres 140 mètres
qui sont en train de dévaster nos côtes
à 5 6 km de nos côtes pour l'instant
c'est légal c'est légal mais la France
pourrait très bien agir et demander à
ses bateaux de partir ces bateaux qui
sont en train de détruire les économies
des pêcheurs artisans sur nos littoraux
voilà ce que la réalité du pouvoir
politique face au lobby de la pêche donc
je suis désolé de rappeler qu'il n'y a
pas de volonté politique pour protéger
l'océan et même pas pour que j'ai
pêcheurs artisans alors c'est quoi c'est
une question de priorité il a fallu se
battre pour obtenir l'accord sur la
déforestation à Bruxelles et moins sur
la pêche voilà j'essaye de c'est une
question un peu un peu basique forcément
je ne suis pas ministre pardon je sais
bien non non mais bon je suis que
représentant d'un établissement public
mais je vous le dis je il y a des
techniques de pêche en effet qui sont
destructrices pour la biodiversité c'est
c'est certain maintenant le sens de
l'histoire c'est de les faire le sens de
l'histoire je pense c'est de permettre
de protéger ces écosystèmes et ces
milieux tout en permettant à l'homme de
vivre c'est ça le sens de l'histoire
donc en effet c'est plutôt développer la
pêche artisanale la pêche qui respecte
la nature comme l'agriculture enfin ce
qui se passe en mer se passe également
sur terre donc c'est pas la question de
savoir si c'est plus important moins
important que la déforestation importée
tous les Condens les combats doivent
être menés vous savez l'ipboys il y a
souvent voilà des compensations il y a
la France on obtient quelque chose sur
un dossier et on lâche on lâche un peu
voilà
la France et membres de l'Union
européenne mais elle est pas la seule ça
va pas échapper bien sûr alors je vais
au premier puissance maritime bon je
vais redonner quelques chiffres parce
que on l'a on l'a évoqué je sais pas si
vous l'avez donné ce chiffre 1 million
d'espèces animales et végétales sur 8
millions qui sont menacés d'extinction
au cours des prochaines décennies et il
y a 69 % des populations d'animaux
sauvages ça c'est un chiffre du WWF qui
sont en en déclin fibre en colère je
reviens un peu au constat sur peut-être
sur le le rythme de ce déclin est-ce
qu'il s'accélère est-ce que
effectivement tout d'abord il est il est
entièrement de cause humaine c'est
exactement l'analogue du changement
climatique et il est mille fois
supérieur ce rythme de déclin un rythme
qui est évalué hors d'influence humaine
c'est-à-dire si on se rapporte aux
périodes qui précèdent l'arrivée de
l'humanité on est 1000 fois plus bas et
en outre on est de 100 à 1000 fois
supérieur en termes de rythme par
rapport aux extinctions des temps
géologiques donc quand on vous parle de
la crise Crétacé tertiaire et de la
disparition progressive des dinosaures
ça s'est passé en quelques millions
d'années
les spéciaux les apparitions d'espèces
qui ont permis quelque part aux
écosystèmes de retrouver un petit peu en
composition une certaine richesse a pris
également quelques centaines de milliers
quelques millions d'années on n'était
pas là aujourd'hui nous sommes là c'est
nous qui sommes la cause de cette
extinction et cette extinction va
extraordinairement vite donc on est
vraiment dans une situation qui est
dramatique de ce point de vue là
d'autant plus qu'il s'agit d'un double
problème à un problème éthique
évidemment on n'est pas on est
dépositaire de cette diversité de la
planète du fait de notre abondance et
notre technologie mais on en est pas
propriétaire à proprement parler et puis
d'autre part il y a un problème
fonctionnel à cette c'est millions
d'espèces qui disparaissent ça peut être
des pollinisateurs ça peut être des
stocks de poissons dont on se nourrit ça
peut être des organismes qui rendent le
sol fertile donc évidemment les
supprimer c'est suicidaires mais Pierre
Dubaï c'est pas forcément effectivement
irréversible on sait aussi
réintroduit ou préserver des espèces bah
oui puisqu'on sait surtout c'est que la
nature et la biodiversité sont
résilientes c'est-à-dire que
contrairement au climat si vous arrêtez
d'émettre du gaz à effet de serre vous
verrez les effets dans quelques dizaines
d'années vous arrêtez de polluer une
rivière j'ai arrêté de polluer l'océan
vous allez voir que les espèces les
milieux et le lien entre ces milieux
vont rapidement mieux se porter donc le
message qu'il faut envoyer il est plutôt
optimiste là en l'occurrence c'est que
si l'homme et la cause l'homme et la
solution par ces pratiques donc on peut
vraiment faire en sorte que la nature se
porte mieux alors pour la question des
sols c'est un peu plus compliqué parce
que la résilience est moins forte mais
pour la plupart des milieux la
résilience est forte donc c'est vraiment
l'action de l'homme qui a un impact sur
la la bonne
bon état d'une espèce et en l'occurrence
il y a des espèces je dis pour le thon
rouge tout à l'heure dès que vous
arrêtez de le péché de le surpêcher et
bien le thon rouge se porte mieux après
vous pouvez continuer le péché de
manière raisonnable tout ça c'est vous
savez il faut juste être raisonnable et
retrouver le sens et la compréhension de
la manière dont la nature fonctionne
avec l'homme un dernier mot claire
nouillon on la solution là pour terminer
je boucle sur les cops on pourrait pas
les réunir de Coop en une parce que
c'est tellement lié le climat la
biodiversité pourquoi pourquoi faire
deux conférences différentes sur le
en faveur de ça parce que ça permettrait
à tout le monde de comprendre que la
biodiversité est une solution pour le
climat que l'océan évidemment absorbe un
tiers des émissions de CO2 que par
contre des méthodes de pêche qui
détruisent tout et réémettent évidemment
le carbone qui est stocké naturellement
tout ça ça marche ensemble les méthodes
de pêche destructrice les méthodes de
prélèvement destructeur en fait ça
marche avec la nature la nature c'est
notre solution climat et aujourd'hui en
effet quand on dit qu'on protège 30% de
nos eaux alors qu'en réalité dans en
France métropolitaine il faut il y a un
chiffre à retenir c'est que la pêche a
accès à
99,9% de nos eaux métropolitaines c'est
ça la réalité de la protection fait
passer le message il est il est il est
et je crois que si mais c'est pas grave
vous avez profité de votre temps de
parole pour le faire merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat et à
bientôt sur public sén